bonjour à tous Nous allons aborder cette
dernière table ronde très stratégique de
la journée avant de passer un autre
moment stratégique je souhaite la
bienvenue à Stéphane séjourd secrétaire
général de renaissance et mon collègue
député européen
nous avons une table ronde très
stratégique et très géostratégique et
vous voyez il faudrait beaucoup plus
d'une heure et demie et je sais qu'on a
quelques contraintes de temps mais où
nous allons traiter ça très bien donc le
thème face l'instabilité d'un monde
multipolaire quelle réponse de l'Union
européenne avant de lancer les débats
avec
autour de Jean-Yves Le Drian monsieur le
ministre merci on est habitué à vous
voir à Guidel et à être accueilli par
voie Guidel merci de participer à cette
table ronde autour de Jean-Louis
burlanche notre commission notre
président pardon de la commission des
affaires étrangères je me tourne aussi
vers Oxana menichou qui est politologue
ukrainienne et Marie-Pierre vedren
député européenne cher Marie-Pierre qui
nous parlera aussi de beaucoup de sujets
liés à l'Union européenne avant de
lancer les débats nous allons regarder
deux vidéos pour
lancer nos réflexions et nos échanges
je suis
ukrainienne d'origine
je viens en France depuis 20 ans et je
suis avocate de profession
pour moi c'était une chose complètement
[Musique]
sauvage qui est arrivé
et à détruit toute la croyance
[Musique]
en bonne entente possible entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine et surtout de
remettre en cause la culture que j'avais
j'ai pas dormi pendant 14 jours on était
tout le temps
en écoutant qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce qu'ils sont encore vivants donc
c'est vrai que
jusqu'au retrait des troupes
russes de quilles c'était vraiment très
très douloureux très très difficile à
supporter pour tout le monde que le
sentiment était la destruction totale
de ce qu'on croyait être son monde enfin
mon monde culturel en graine et que
l'Europe
a décidé de faire un geste également
pour accepter la candidature de
l'Ukraine pour moi c'était vraiment une
[Musique]
tellement tellement puissant comme
signal que les Ukrainiens ont cru que
oui ça va être possible de réussir de
combattre tout ça parce que aujourd'hui
si on ne se tient pas l'Ukraine c'est
l'Europe qui est la suivante pour
pour affronter ce malin
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
je voulais d'abord livrer un témoignage
je suis depuis le 24 février un député
en zone de guerre je me suis rendu
plusieurs fois en
Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre à
Kiev puis à 80 km de la frontière avec
la Russie avec le Belarus ce qui m'a
beaucoup marqué dans cette dans la
population que j'ai rencontrée dans mes
collègues députés c'est leur résilience
et leur lucidité évidemment le peuple
craignant cette agression la rassemblé
autour de sa nation mais je crois aussi
que ce qui est important pour nous au
modèle c'est de se rappeler qu'il s'est
rassemblé aussi autour de ces
institutions démocratiques pas
uniquement la présidence de gélinski
mais également les mairies également le
Parlement qui travaille énormément on
touche là quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la différence entre les deux
modèles qui sont en conflit aujourd'hui
en Ukraine notre modèle de coopération
européenne depuis 80 ans c'est que
l'économie est un outil pour faire la
paix l'économie est un outil pour
dépasser nos conflits dans
l'impérialisme et en particulier dans
l'impérialisme de la Fédération de
Russie dirigée par le KGB en fait et
bien l'économie c'est une arme de guerre
c'est centralisée aux mains du pouvoir
et bien nous devons reconstruire
aujourd'hui parce que c'est une
résistance nous devons aller
reconstruire aider à la reconstruction
aujourd'hui si nous commençons cette
reconstruction dans notre état d'esprit
nous serons aussi quelque part au front
et nous serons aussi à la place où je
pense notre mouvement doit être
après
après ces témoignages poignants de Yulia
Lepage et de Frédéric petit nous allons
bien sûr nous consacrer au répercussions
de la guerre en Ukraine sur l'ordre du
monde sur l'action de l'Union européenne
alors
l'invasion de Vladimir Poutine en
Ukraine a déclenché une salle de
réaction sans précédent que j'imagine
Vladimir Poutine lui-même n'aurait pas
imaginé l'Union européenne a réagi dès
le premier jour de l'invasion avec une
force unique puisque il était question à
la fois
d'assécher au plus vite les finances de
la Russie
d'aider les réfugiés Ukrainiens d'armée
l'Ukraine ce qui était aussi un fait
sans précédent pour l'Union européenne
et puis bien sûr d'accélérer
l'intégration de l'Ukraine mais aussi de
pays de voisinage
à l'Union européenne en accélérant
l'accession au statut de candidat et
également en créant cette nouvelle
communauté politique européenne voulue
par le président de la République
alors ces décisions elles ont un prix le
prix de l'énergie qui peuvent être très
déstabilisantes aussi au sein de même de
l'Union européenne on peut le voir
aujourd'hui avec la montée des extrêmes
Suède on est je sais que sandrogozzi en
parler précédemment avec l'Italie ces
décisions elles ont une répercussion en
Europe mais aussi au delà puisque elles
ont bouleversé les plans des États-Unis
elles ont bouleversé aussi les positions
de la Chine qui ne peut se couper de
bien sûr de l'Union européenne et
surtout du marché européen on le verra
avec Marie-pierre vedren
Oxanna je vais bien sûr commencer avec
vous puisque l'ouverture le nécessite en
vous disant bien sûr toute le choc que
nous avons eu avec la découverte des
dernières exactions de de l'armée russe
en Ukraine
mais aussi cette on les a découvertes
parce que
l'armée Ukraine l'armée russe avait
abandonné les territoires donc que
peut-on dire aujourd'hui peut-on dire
que
Vladimir Poutine a perdu la guerre alors
même qu'il
brandissent cette menace nucléaire qui
l'organise ses référendum on en parlera
et qu'il a il connaît des déboires sur
la scène internationale avec ses alliés
historiques
avant de répondre à votre question j'ai
vaudrait tout d'abord vous remercier
tous de la part des Ukrainiens par aide
considérable et pour para solidarité une
nuit que nous avons senti de votre part
dès le premier jour de la guerre j'ai au
titre bien évolue j'ai travaillé avec le
président ukrainien pour assurer la
communication avec les prix pays
francophones comme beaucoup d'autres
gens de la profession de communication
on a été tous mobilisés pour aider notre
président assuré sa communication avec
le monde entier et dans les premières
jours j'étais en contact avec Jean-Louis
bollange on se connaissait pas encore à
l'époque j'étais dans la cave avec les
enfants on a parlé parce que Starling
nous assurer la connexion d'Internet
même dans les caves très profondes même
dans les métros très profondes et
les enfants étaient très énervés et je
dis j'ai la France à la ligne
n'empêchait pas de parler
communauté comme dans les contes des
films à regarder et quand j'ai accroché
j'ai dit c'était le Parlement français
ils sont avec nous ils vont nous aider
et eux ils ont eu comme à la fin de la
conte que le méchant n'est battue et que
le bien il a gagné et pour moi c'était
ça qu'on a ressenti chaque fois avec
cette solidarité de vous donc c'est ça
qui nous donne la courage et je pense
que Poutine elle a perdu tout de suite
dès que la solidarité européenne était
montée mais vous connaissez sans doute
toutes les détails comment comment cette
solidarité a développé il faut
reconnaître les efforts les efforts
incroyables de France qui était en
présidence c'est à ce moment-là
on sait un derrière de coulisses quelle
Bata était dans le Parlement au même
européenne pour obtenir la majorité dans
le Parlement donc après les victoires on
doit fêter tout ça ensemble mais je
voudrais pour répondre maintenant plus
analyse et plus stratégiquement à vos
questions je voudrais étirer votre
attention à doux événement majeurs je
pense changer le tournant de la guerre
considérablement le premier événement
c'était le sommet le fameux sommet à
Ouzbékistan
camp Poutine a eu essayé de réunir ses
alliés
et ce n'est pas marché bon vous avez
vous connaissez sans doute toutes les
toutes les détails je vais pas revenir
dessus bon Poutine il a pensé d'obtenir
l'aide des militaires il paraît c'est
une information vous savez les taxi que
ce sont très grands amis de l'Ukraine et
on a toujours les insights de leur part
c'était pas très bien couvert par les
journalistes mais on a les Insight de
leur part
ils sont réunis pour dire non en petit
en fait leur intention c'était pour le
calmer un peu et toutes les discours que
vous avez entendu c'était discours qui
était bien préparé il y avait un
solidarité de leur côté il paraît que
Poutine elle a eu malaise mais vraiment
une malaise physique quand il a dit il a
reçu nom de la part de Chine ici vous
avez vu les images il était entretenu
par Erdogan vous avez aperçu peut-être
que petit il était vraiment tenu par le
bras par Erdogan c'est parce qu'il a il
a eu du mal à marcher il n'a pas
participé à un balade qui était prévu
après pour vous contempler une ancienne
ville Samarcande donc c'est une grande
défaite de Poutine et dans une semaine
nous avons une autre sommet à l'ONU
comme une réponse à une semaine
précédente et qu'est-ce que nous avons
vu sur cette semaine
moi pour moi ce qui était le plus
marquant ces trois discours qui
tournaient le monde
premièrement c'est le discours de
président Macron
deuxièmement c'est le discours du baiden
et troisième discours c'est discours du
président zzinski tous les trois
discours ce sont les discours politiques
bien forts qu'on n'a pas entendu depuis
longtemps n'est-ce pas monsieur le
ministre vous me corrigez si je me
trompe
je dois vous reconnaître que président
Macron était brillant en tant que
politologue j'ai applaudis debout
vraiment parce que je pouvais saigner
pour chaque mot j'ai pris j'ai pris
plein citations que je cite maintenant
partout je peux et
essentiel ce que Macron il nous a donné
les nouvelles vision de l'Europe ils
n'ont posé les tâches les objectifs que
nous devons bon je vais pas répéter vous
avez tous suivi tout ça mais encore un
fois avec le drapeau français et la
montrer il a réglé le leadership
français
dans tout ce qui est la différence des
valeurs et ça c'est très important parce
que dans notre monde de l'économie
globale on a un peu perdu la notion des
valeurs et je pense que c'était très
belle que c'est la France avec l'immo
pour les Ukrainiens ce sont les mots
très chers libertés égalité infraternité
c'est avec ces mots qui ont YouTube
maintenant et la France et la montée un
nouveau ce drapeau à l'Union il a
confirmé sa position de soutien pour la
démocratie les libertés pour laquelle
nous nous donne avec l'arme dans leur
Ukraine la deuxième discours super
importante c'est le discours du baiden
qui était complètement refait juste
après le discours de Poutine
et on trouve en Ukraine que le discours
de bayden c'était la nouvelle vision de
l'économie mondiale en fait parce que si
avant on a parlé de la
libertanisme dans la dans l'économie
libertale maintenant on a pensé
les plus capitalistes dur possible ils
ont parlé de l'économie sociale de
partage de solidarité avec c'était en
écho avec tout ce qui disait Macron mais
quand président français disent les
choses pareilles c'est attendu mais
quand le président américain parle de la
solidarité avec les autres pays ça c'est
rassurant plutôt donc il est troisième
discours du discours de président
Zelinski qui nous a tous réunis
à l'humanisation
quand on parle de victimes de l'Ukraine
quand on parle de toute cette massacre
et toutes ces atrocités
qu'on observe presque chaque jour quand
on parle de cette terrorisme notre
Président il voulait revenir faire
revenir tout le monde entier à cette
nation de valeur de la vie il faut
réhumaniser l'humanité maintenant et
dans le cadre de cette
retour à humanisation
nous avons une groupe des penseurs des
philosophes politiques des analystes
Ukrainiens qui travaillent déjà avec les
Russes avec les positions russes pour
penser la Russie après la guerre donc on
peut dire que Poutine il a gagné la
guerre dès les premières jours dès que
la solidarité était montée on peut on
peut on peut confirmer que
la solidarité
surtout avec le leadership de l'Union
européenne et les considérable c'est une
centre de gravité dans cette guerre et
d'ailleurs vous connaissez sans doute
notre général zalujnies qui est le chef
de l'armée ukrainien je pense que après
la guerre quand elle sera plus plus en
communication on va découvrir en grand
génie de stratégie militaires
contemporains lui il parle de cette
gravité de la guerre cette solidarité
européenne et
je voudrais vous assurer que les
Ukrainiens ils
rejoint les mots de notre général de la
chair de l'armée ukrainien nous ne
sommes pas Vatan guerre
on n'est pas dans l'esprit de vengeance
nous punitions non nous sommes dans
l'esprit de la justice nous voudrions
notre grand espoir et c'est ça que nous
attendons maintenant de la communauté
internationale que la guerre
avant de passer au dialogue la guerre
doit terminer par les justices
internationales par la justice et après
on va voir
quel corridor de sortie nous pouvons
proposer au peuple russe
après avoir passé par la justice
internationale pour faire revenir les
Russie dans le monde de droit parce que
le discours de Poutine qu'il a menait
juste pour mobilisation c'était les
discours des années 80 du siècle
précédent c'était les discours de
l'époque de la guerre froide on a
l'impression que ce vieux monsieur il
est toujours dans cette époque là qu'il
n'a pas sorti de l'époque précédent on a
déjà 40 ans d'après la guerre froide
donc il est le temps de penser de Russie
moderne et ça existe la Russie moderne
contemporaine ça existe et vous avez vu
toute cette enlèvement des ils sont
levés quand même les Russes bien merci
donc nous pensons que maintenant notre
grande tâche c'est travailler ensemble
pour faire revenir la Russie dans le
monde d'où l'ordre de démocratie de la
respect des autres et comme ça c'est ça
l'avenir de l'Europe en fait merci au
Xéna je pense que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-il affaibli par cette politique zéro
covid par cette question de la
dénatalité qu'est-ce que ça dit cet
appel au cessez-le-feu cette
ce retrait de d'une neutralité complice
en fait avec avec Vladimir Poutine
je merci beaucoup Laurence je salue
l'arrivée de Edouard Philippe le premier
ancien Premier ministre
merci tout d'abord Roxana de vos mots et
je crois que tous les applaudissements
de la salle à l'issue de votre
intervention témoigne bien de l'unité en
tout cas vous l'avez dit du Parlement
européen des Européens que nous tenons à
avoir bien sûr en soutien avec vous
parce que vous l'avez rappelé ce n'est
pas qu'une
atteinte à votre intégrité territoriale
mais c'est bien au-delà et pour nous
nous le rappelons Parlement européen
spécifiquement notre famille politique
que c'est une atteinte à la liberté à la
démocratie et Laurence a raison de
souligner que
la Chine joue un drôle de jeu et que
certainement c'est vrai qu'on peut
croire qu'il y a une évolution de la
position de zing-bling qui est mis en
difficulté en interne dans son pays tu
as évoqué et François à l'évoques
souvent que ça soit la question de la
natalité que ce soit la politique du
zéro covid mais je crois qu'il faut pas
pour autant
croire qu'il a totalement changé de
position et qu'il serait en opposition
et à la Russie et en soutien que ça soit
à l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne et aux
Américains je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus difficile que ça et du coup je
referai un retour en arrière sur
pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'on cherche à
porter à l'Union européenne et
spécifiquement nous notre délégation
notre groupe politique vis-à-vis de
cette relation avec la Chine
rappelez-vous déjà dès 2019 comment nous
qualifions la Chine d'un partenaire
parce qu'on sait qu'on a besoin de la
Chine notamment pour relever la question
du changement climatique un concurrent
économique et notre dépendance notamment
mise en exergue avec le choc du covid
nous l'a montré et un rival systémique
une fois qu'on a fait ce constat il faut
créer bien évidemment l'ambition
politique pour répondre à ces
difficultés et tous les leviers qu'ils
soient législatif politique aussi sur le
industriel et c'est là où c'est notre
rôle en tant que parlementaire européen
c'est ce que le président de la
République poussait déjà dans le
discours de la Sorbonne avec l'Europe
sur rubaine et c'est ce que nous mettons
en oeuvre au quotidien au Parlement
européen pour concrétiser donner cher
donner cœur à l'autonomie stratégique
faire en sorte que l'Union européenne
elle est la capacité de décider par
elle-même avec qui quand comment elle
veut établir des relations avec le reste
du monde et c'est ça véritablement notre
enjeu et c'est aussi le président de la
République le rappeler dans la je salue
Sarah en y était ensemble au moment de
la rentrée des ambassadeurs en disant
nous ne sommes pas équidistance entre
l'union entre les États-Unis et la Chine
mais c'est important de ne pas perdre de
vue qu'il nous faut aussi un agenda
positif avec la Chine notamment pour
répondre aux enjeux du dérèglement
climatique et on a énormément de
questions vis-à-vis aussi des droits de
l'homme en Chine et c'est là où la
politique commerciale a un rôle
fondamental à jouer parce que ce qui
peut faire aussi bouger machine c'est
l'accès à notre marché intérieur on le
voit bien
ils vendent énormément nous sommes le
premier partenaire commercial de la
Chine donc fermez l'accès à notre marché
est un levier qui peut les faire bouger
et on l'a vu au Parlement européen quand
on a bloqué ce fameux accord
d'investissement entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine il y a eu des
inflexions aussi président de la
République a porté énormément de choses
pour inclure une clause relative au
droit de l'homme donc c'est un premier
point mais c'est pas suffisant et
d'autres exemples quand la Lituanie un
État membre de l'Union européenne a
souhaité faire soutenir davantage Taïwan
dans l'émergence de la démocratie de la
liberté qu'est-ce qu'a fait la Chine
elle leur a coupé l'accès notamment à
leur marché elle utilise et Frédéric
petit le disait dans sa vidéo le
commerce l'économie est une arme et nous
sommes complètement des munis au niveau
de l'Union européenne pour lutter contre
la coercition économique c'est pourquoi
durant la présidence française et on y
travaille maintenant on a porté un
instrument pour lutter contre la
coercition économique et notre enjeu
notre détermination Parlement européen
c'est de préserver cette unité
européenne pour véritablement faire
bouger la ligne parce qu'on le sait bien
aussi la Chine elle a la stratégie 16+1
elle cherche seulement à nous diviser et
c'est de cette division que nous ne
répondrons pas à ces enjeux donc nous y
arrivons progressivement nous avons déjà
fait changer de paradigme au sein de
l'Union européenne l'entièreté des
amendes spécifiquement l'Allemagne parce
que il ne faut pas se cacher l'Allemagne
aussi à des grands intérêts de présence
dans la Chine de vente de son parc
automobile mais nous aussi nous avons
des investisseurs français présents en
Chine et on le voit justement tu
évoquais Laurence cette stratégie zéro
covid nos investisseurs français ils
sont qui ont investi en Chine sont
complètement déstabilisés aussi par la
politique de begin donc il y a tous ces
éléments d'instabilité et c'est bien le
le titre aussi de notre théba on voit
des menaces de plus en plus nombreuses
et il faut qu'on soit paré et c'est ce
que notamment aussi Monsieur le Ministre
cher Jean-Yves vous avez cherché à faire
au sein des différents conseils au sein
de l'Union européenne être prêt ne plus
être dépendant d'un ou tel acteur qu'il
soit étatique ou qu'il soit économique
et donc on continue de le faire chaque
jour au Parlement européen
merci
Jean-Louis bourlange je continue la
revue du monde avec les États-Unis qui
après 20 ans passés aux États-Unis
c'était retiré de notre continent de nos
problèmes de sécurité pour se recentrer
à la fois sur leurs affaires intérieures
dans une société extrêmement fracturée
mais aussi pour se tourner vers
l'Indo-Pacifique alors ce conflit en
Ukraine
c'est un peu la patrouille qu'il est
rattrape il revienne vers nous pour être
réinvestis très fortement dans les
relations transatlantiques comment vous
voyez la suite de cette inflexion avec
les parties pris très forts que Capri
Joey
oui c'est effectivement il s'est passé
depuis 18 mois des Jean-Yves Le Drian
l'a vécu agit tout au long de cette
période avec énormément de détermination
de talent et d'esprit de responsabilité
il s'est passé des choses
extraordinaires
songez à la situation qui était la nôtre
vis-à-vis des États-Unis il y a une
quinzaine de mois une douzaine de mois
qu'est-ce qu'on avait on avait une fuite
en catastrophe des États-Unis de
l'Afghanistan un effondrement total et
mal préparé mal prévu un calendrier qui
n'avait pas du tout été anticipé
correctement par l'administration
américaine en conclu en conclusion des
accords de Doha passé entre les Afghans
les les talibans et l'administration
américaine accorde détestable puisque
toutes les concessions qui devaient être
faites devaient être faites par les
Américains avant l'arrivée au pouvoir
des talibans et les concessions des
talibans devaient avoir lieu après
autant dire qu'elles n'ont jamais eu
lieu donc on a eu vraiment une
déconfiture très profonde avec un
sentiment très grave de de
déstabilisation la deuxième chose plus
profonde mais qui nous concernait
directement aussi c'était le pivot le
pivot américain vers le Pacifique qui
impliquait un désintérêt relatif mais
réel à l'égard du théâtre européen je me
rappelle qu'à la commission des affaires
étrangères en septembre dernier nous
avions reçu mes trois homologues des
commissions des affaires étrangères des
États baltes qui étaient tous les trois
extrêmement soucieux de solidarité
Atlantique et extrêmement préoccupé en
même temps du fait qu'ils attendaient
que les États-Unis leur demandent de
mettre la douce vis-à-vis des
menaces russes parce que considérait-il
à l'époque et il y a une part importante
de vérité comme Marie-Pierre Vienne le
rappeler dans cette observation que
c'était la Chine le numéro 1 et qu'il
fallait donc faire des concessions sur
sur l'Ukraine sur toutes les sortes de
de revendications des des Russes et
surtout ne pas gêner les réalisations
des infrastructures de transport gazier
donc on avait cette cette réalité là
troisièmement on a eu une crise majeur
Majeur et une crise de confiance absolue
avec l'affaire de Locus ou véritablement
les Américains les Britanniques
et les Australiens ont ce sont conduits
d'une façon extrêmement inconvenante à
l'égard de leurs alliés français alors
même que nous étions la première
puissance européenne la première
puissance militaire de l'Union
européenne que nous avions engagé avec
le président Biden des relations qui
semblaient prometteuses de normalisation
de nos relations tout ça et Jean-Yves Le
Drian l'a vécu en direct et lui qui
avait été à l'origine du de la
conclusion des accords sur les
sous-marins français ça a été quelque
chose d'extrêmement pénible voilà la
situation une Amérique
en situation de perdition en Afghanistan
une Amérique désengagée sur le vieux
théâtre européen et une Amérique qui
n’hésitait pas à créer une crise
vraiment injustifiée avec son plus
anciennes et et
son allié le plus solide sur le plan
militaire en Europe quand on regarde la
situation aujourd'hui tout est
fondamentalement différent
Biden je crois qu'on doit rendre hommage
à l'administration du président Biden de
la façon dont elle a géré jusqu'à
présent l'affaire
ukrainienne il a eu un instant non pas
d'hésitation mais d'attentes
il s'agissait de savoir si on allait
offrir au président Zelinski un taxi ou
des munitions pour reprendre les
formules du président Zelenski lui-même
et quand on a vu la détermination
ukrainienne quand on a vu l'échec
initial des Russes qui n'était pas gagné
les Russes ont été à deux doigts de
réussir leur opération c'est vraiment la
la vigueur inattendue la réaction
ukrainienne qui a permis d'éviter que
les soldats russes paradent dans les
rues de Kiev assez rapidement quand on a
vu cela les États-Unis ont réagi de
façon extrêmement forte extrêmement
responsable et il s'est passé quelque
chose de de tout à fait formidable sur
le plan européen deuxième événement donc
un réinsertion des Russes des Américains
sur le théâtre européen sur ce dossier
fondamental deuxièmement redécouverte
par les Européens par les par l'Union
européenne de la dimension géopolitique
de notre union c'était pas évident
l'Union européenne a été bâtie pour la
paix elle n'a pas été bâtie pour la
guerre elle pour
aplanir les frontières elle a pas été
abâtie pour les défendre elle a elle a
été bâtie pour créer l'embryon d'une
société universelle et non pas un bloc
géopolitique face à d'autres blogs
géopolitiques malgré tout on a pris tout
à fait conscience que il fallait comme
autant de la guerre froide il fallait
absolument défendre les valeurs
européennes que les valeurs européennes
ça passait par la défense de l'intégrité
territoriale de de la de l'Ukraine et il
s'est passé des choses formidables
notamment en Allemagne on a vu à ce
moment-là que l'Allemagne a pris
conscience des limites pour ne pas dire
plus des limites même enfin un peu plus
quand même des contradictions et des et
la désinvolture avec laquelle elle avait
envisagé
les années antérieures ces relations
avec la Russie le président
a fait plusieurs interventions
extrêmement nettes à cet égard et
l'Union européenne renoue avec ceux qui
étaient essentiel à nos yeux puisque
nous avons toujours été partisans de ce
qu'on a appelé l'Europe puissance je
dirais plus volontiers l'Europe
puissante l'Europe qui se défend et
c'est quelque chose de très très
fondamentale troisièmement l'ensemble
l'OTAN qui était en mort cérébrale selon
le on a découvert à ce moment là que
l'Europe que le temps n'était pas en
morse cérébrale mais que le temps ait
été en coma profond la différence entre
la mort cérébrale et comme un profond
c'est qu'on en ressort du coma profond
comme Jean-Pierre Chevènement un moment
on en ressort dans de ces bonnes
conditions j'ai vu Jean-Pierre
Chevènement j'étais avec lui en Algérie
avec le président de la République il
m'a dit ah bah quand même moi j'ai
disparu de la j'ai disparu de la vie
pendant pas mal de minutes et voyez je
suis toujours là effectivement il était
toujours là le temps c'est la même chose
on s'est aperçu qu'il était sorti et non
seulement cela mais il s'est passé des
choses très importantes le Danemark a
renoncé à son opting out sur le plan de
la politique extérieure la Finlande et
la Suède ont retrouvé le chemin le temps
qui fait que maintenant on a plus je
crois que deux États neutres l'Autriche
et l'Irlande l'Irlande cette façon c'est
pas grave parce qu'ils sont ils ont un
président américain qui est qui est
irlandais donc ils sont ils sont dans le
temps d'honneur si je puis dire et la
plupart des la plupart des puissances
européennes ont décidé de faire un
accord avec
avec le temps et on a donc dans dans
lié la défense de l'Europe et la Défense
de l'Occident et en même temps nous
avons affirmé la boussole stratégique et
la volonté de construire une unité alors
est-ce que tout va bien non tout ne va
pas bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont encore très inquiétantes
et qui demandent effectivement
premièrement clémente effectivement des
initiatives notre art d'abord la mue
allemande n'est pas finie n'est pas fait
loin de là on voit les Allemands ont
fait un effort quantitatif majeur ils
ont ils décident de mettre de l'argent
pour rétablir leur solidarité pleine
avec le temps en même temps
stratégiquement ils n'ont pas fait
jusqu'à présent d'évolution vers
l'affirmation d'une autonomie d'une
autonomie militaire européenne loin de
là l'argent servira pour beaucoup à
acheter du matériel américain il faut
pas être totalement négatif là-dessus il
est normal que quand les Américains nous
apportent leur concours y est une
certaine contrepartie enfin il faut
quand même équilibrer les choses et il
quand même se rappeler que nous avons
une industrie européenne d'armement et
que celle-ci doit être développée je
crois que l'incertitude sur les
perspectives que l'Allemagne donne à
l'autonomie militaire européenne et est
assez et est assez impressionnant
deuxièmement on a l'incertitude
américain nous avons Biden et nous ont
félicitons
aurons-nous demain quelque chose comme
Trump ou un similitrum ça serait
préoccupant songez à scorer était la
réaction de l'Occident je finis si Trump
avait
citron avait été aux affaires et non pas
Biden c'était c'était tout à fait
impressionnant troisièmement nous avons
nous-mêmes nous n'avons pas clarifié nos
responsabilités stratégiques l'article 5
de le temps et l'article 42 7 de l'Union
européenne post postule des solidarités
absolument
identiques que faisons-nous que
faisons-nous si les Américains sont
défaillants nous sommes loin d'avoir
pensé la question et dernièrement je
termine là-dessus nous avons nos
profondes incertitudes européennes qui
se manifesteront demain dans les urnes à
Rome en Italie nous avons effectivement
nous sommes partagés nous sommes
partagés en France nous avons des
parties qui sont proches de de la Russie
nous avons une réaction anti-otens qui
reste très forte nous avons des
incertitudes américaines très lassitude
européenne très profonde sur la défense
donc chers amis vraiment
continuons le combat
merci j'en veux blanche pour cette
analyse et cette discipline merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre le 24
février c'était deux mois 24 février
donc date de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
c'était deux mois après le début de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne
il y avait beaucoup de sujets sur la
souveraineté l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Union européenne dans la feuille de
route de cette présidence pour autant
cette invasion est venue percuter
l'agenda politique comme on l'appelle et
la France a été vraiment à la manœuvre
pour faire avancer toutes les décisions
très rapides qui ont été prises pour
condamner pour décider des sanctions
pour engager l'Union européenne dans
cette
démarche très politique que nous
attendions en tant que groupe politique
et puis pour aboutir à cette fameuse
adoption de la boussole stratégique
alors est-ce qu'on peut revenir sur ces
six mois particuliers et puis sur votre
vision bien sûr générale de de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui et de ces nouveaux
équilibres merci
bonjour à François Bayrou et Édouard
Philippe je suis heureux de retrouver
bonjour à tous et à toutes je suis un
peu habitué de ces rencontres et comme
certains peuvent vous d'entre vous le
savent j'ai été dans une vie très
antérieure députée de cette
circonscription
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps parce que c'est la
conscription qui a été redécoupée après
et je ne sais pas si Jean-Michel Jacque
est là je n'ai pas vu mais enfin ici il
m'a succédé indirectement et puis petit
secret familial et personnel j'étais
animateur quand j'étais très jeune de ce
village de vacances ici
en direct
on aura aujourd'hui on dirait 10 que le
Joker mais à ce moment-là on disait
animateur bon donc je suis très con je
suis très content d'être là
si je peux me permettre de rebondir un
peu sur ce qu'a dit Jean-Louis bourlange
[Musique]
et pour répondre aussi à Roxane à tout à
l'heure je crois qu'il y a sur la crise
ukrainienne
5 sous estimations
de du président Poutine qui se cumulent
et qui aboutissent à cet impact il faut
bien les analyser parce que elle se
renforce mutuellement et je crois que ça
nous aide pour pour l'appréciation les
situations et Jean-Louis en a évoqué
quelques unes il y a une première
sous-estimation c'est la force
ukrainienne
la nation ukrainienne indirectement le
président Poutine a contribué à
solidifier la nation ukrainienne moi je
suis allé en Ukraine avant la guerre
plusieurs fois c'était pas toujours très
facile honnêtement et l'unité de la
nation elle était pas automatiquement au
rendez-vous les volontés collectives
n'étaient pas affirmées et là le
changement était considérable
du fait de l'intervention russe
sous-estimation forte de la capacité
ukrainienne de deuxième sous-estimation
sous-estimation de la force de
réactivité européenne
je pense que le président Poutine
n'allait pas penser qu'il y aurait une
telle unité une telle rapidité dans la
mise en oeuvre de sanctions vont
peut-être revenir sur les sanctions tout
à l'heure dans la discussion elles sont
elles sont réelles et elles pèsent de
plus en plus mais il avait sous-estimé
cette capacité collective de l'Union
européenne qui a été en responsabilité à
ce moment-là sous
française
extrêmement extrêmement rapide deux
jours après les sanctions étaient
dessinées deux jours après le 24 le 26 à
Paris donc c'était tout à fait
impressionnant et ça s'est poursuivi il
y a eu une permanence de l'unité
européenne dans la réaction par rapport
aux enjeux de sanction en particulier et
puis dans la réaction de soutien à
l'Ukraine en terme de soutien financier
et de soutien militaire sous deuxième
sous-estimation qui se cumule avec la
première troisième sous-estimation la
sous-estimation de la
les conséquences sur le temps
parce que pour revenir ce que ce que
disait Jean-Louis bourlange nous allons
passer sur le temps une période
d'incertitude c'était pas uniquement la
mort cérébrale c'était des risques il y
avait une période de doute
quand le président Trump
s'interrogeait sur l'effectivité de la
mise en œuvre de l'article 5 je pense au
mot tenego les pauvres monténégrin qui
venaient de rentrer dans l'Union dans
l'alliance et qui se voyait entendre
dire je sais pas si j'irai sur le
Monténégro donc c'était quand même pas
très satisfaisant donc il y avait un
doute sur la solidité de de la riposte
sur l'article 5 et puis il y avait aussi
une inquiétude sur une fuite en avant de
l'OTAN qui ce serait traduit par une
alliance qui aurait désormais comme
priorité le Pacifique et non pas
l'espace roi Atlantique sur lequel le
temps s'est fondé
troisième sous-estimation parce que en
fait la graission de la Russie à l'égard
de l'Ukraine a amené la clarification et
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
alliance clarifiée depuis le sommet de
Madrid à la fois sur son espace
d'intervention et sur sa solidité
interne non seulement clarification mais
en plus
élargissement puisque ce que je disais
Jean-Louis
l'agression russe a aboutit au fait que
et la Finlande et la Suède qui la Suède
est quitté neutre depuis 300 ans ont
rallié le temps c'est l'inverse du but
de rechercher par le président Poutine
quatrième sous-estimation l'état de son
armée
je dois dire qu'il est pas le seul à
voir sous-estimé
de la défense je pense que nous avions
sous-estimé il y a toute une série de
régions à cela que l'on voit apparaître
maintenant jour après jour mais il
n'empêche que cette sous-estimation
était très forte et elle s'accumulent
par rapport aux quatre ou trois autres
que je viens de citer et puis il y en a
une cinquième qui est récente mais qui
est très perturbante et que et que
Roxana a évoqué c'est c'est le le
soutien international pendant un certain
temps
des pays qu'on dit Non Alignés
avaient hésité parce qu'il considérait
pour une partie d'entre eux par intérêt
pour préserver l'avenir pour éviter de
se fâcher avec les uns les autres ou
peut-être par conviction pour certains
que c'était une guerre en
occidentaux finalement que c'était une
règlement de compte entre blanc pour
pour dire les choses brutalement ce
n'est de moins en moins le cas on l'a vu
au moment de la sobre général des
Nations unies je crois que le président
Macron a bien fait de stigmatiser cette
posture mais on l'a vu surtout à sa
marque Horn au finalement dans cette
organisation de la coopération dite de
coopération de Shanghai le président
Poutine n'a pas eu les soutiens réels
qu'ils pouvaient attendre de la part de
partenaires importants en particulier le
partenaire chinois parce que comme ça a
été dit tout à l'heure par Marie-Pierre
la Chine n'a pas aujourd'hui intérêt à
voir un conflit de cette nature sur son
développement économique parce que ça
peut lui poser des problèmes ça commence
déjà à lui imposer sur son équilibre
intérieur la veille du 20e congrès du
Parti communiste chinois donc une
situation de sous-estimation accumulée
qui aboutit à la réalité de
d'aujourd'hui qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer non plus nous moi je suis
quand même
très réservée lorsque je vois
l'enthousiasme de nos médias
sur les percées ukrainiennes que nous
applaudissons très fort mais il
n'empêche que je pense que cette crise
sera encore longue il faut saluer
l'obstination du peuple
ukrainien et dire ici moi je le dis très
très franchement
je ne suis plus responsabilité donc j'ai
une relative liberté mais je pense que
c'est un point de vue qui est partagé ce
sont les Ukrainiens qui doivent fixer
des conditions de la négociation
il faut le redire
c'est ce qu'a dit le président Macron
peut-être que d'autres pensent autrement
donc disons le très clairement je
voudrais faire une deuxième remarque et
j'en aurai terminé qui est plus lié à
votre propre question
j'ai vécu 10 ans de responsabilité dans
des domaines très sensibles
je constate un double mouvement
il y a d'abord
l'accentuation de la brutalisation et de
la conflictualité dans le monde moi j'ai
vécu ça de manière accentuée accélérée
avec l'accumulation des crises j'ai pas
en faire des numération mais il a eu
beaucoup et ça se poursuit avec la crise
ukrainienne nous sommes dans des
situations où il n'y a plus de règles ou
l'ordre international qui avait été mise
en œuvre après la guerre
39-45 avec la création des Nations Unies
qui reposait sur le respect du droit
international qui reposait sur
l'intégralité des frontières sur le
respect de chaque pays et sur le fait
qu'on était en commun notre action pour
les biens communs ça c'est tombé et
certains ont passé leur temps à essayer
d'affaiblir les institutions
internationales je pense au président
Trump aller bloquer je pense à la Russie
au les détourner je pense à la Chine
voilà quelle est la situation très grave
dans laquelle nous sommes le désordre du
monde est croissant
je vais pas en faire un numéro
dramatique mais mais c'est vraiment la
leçon que je retire d'une accélération
au bout des au cours des 10 ans qui
viennent de s'écouler et puis
parallèlement
une un réveil géostratégique de l'Europe
et le seul point mais il est majeur
d'optimisme que j'ai là maintenant c'est
le fait de constater que l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec
l'Europe il y a 10 ans encore mais même
rien à voir avec l'Europe il y a 5 ans
les termes d'aujourd'hui les termes
forts souveraineté puissance autonomie
stratégique sont désormais partagés par
tous et quand on voit le chantier les
scholls dans son discours de Prague il y
a quelques jours que c'était Jean-Louis
bourlange
reprendre ces mots-là
de la part des Allemands c'est une
avancée considérable nous sommes dans
une nouvelle donne européenne et je
pense que le discours de Prax était
finalement une réponse indirecte avec 50
retard au discours de la Sorbonne du
président du président Macron mais c'est
une source d'espoir l'Europe
se rend compte qu'elle a développé
jusqu'à présent sa propre stratégie dans
une espèce de confort un peu en dehors
du monde comme quoi
les fondamentaux qui étaient à la fois
le marché intérieur source de progrès
source de développement ce qu'il a été
et les valeurs historiques de notre de
notre civilisation et de l'Europe
c'était ce pouvait se développer en
renforçant la démocratie ce n'est plus
le cas nous sommes passés d'une Europe
de la protection à une Europe de la
projection et là tous les chemins que
vous partagez que nous partageons
ensemble sur l'avenir de l'Europe reste
ouvert et c'est particulièrement vrai de
l'Europe de la défense peut-être qu'on
aura le temps d'y revenir mais je le dis
là à l'instant je terminerai là-dessus
et il fut un temps quand j'étais mise à
la défense je me souviens d'avoir
proposé avec Madame vanderne Allianz qui
était ministre allemand à l'époque de la
défense un truc petit de coopération
entre les Européens on voulait proposer
que en application du traité de Lisbonne
j'ai plus quel article la coopération
structurée permanente qu'on appelle ça
la coopération structurée permanente la
CSP on puisse mettre ensemble nos
services de santé entre l'Allemagne et
la France est quand même pas une
révolution et mais pour que nous
puissions le faire il fallait l'accord
des autres c'était en 2016 nous n'avons
pas eu nous avons été traités à l'époque
Ursula et moi-même de gens qui voulaient
sortir de l'OTAN substituer la défense
européenne à l'OTAN
créer une armée européenne autonome
enfin toutes sortes de choses
aujourd'hui non seulement tout le monde
mes membres de la de la coopération
structurée permanente les 27 mais en
plus de ça on a progressé en matière de
défense de manière inimaginable par
rapport à ces réticences que nous
constatons à ce moment-là parce que nous
avons créé le Fonds européen de défense
mobilisant 8 milliards je crois de de
d'euros sur sur la période parce que
nous avons décidé de créer la
facilité européenne de paix qu'on
appelle la facilité européenne de paix
qui permet de mobiliser des financements
de soutien aux pays qui sont dans la
difficulté et que nous avons utilisé
pour 2 milliards et demi pour le
l'Ukraine parce que nous avons acheté
des armes pour l'étal pour les données à
l'Ukraine les Européens c'était
inimaginable il y a quelques années et
parce que nous avons abouti à la
boussole stratégique qui est en fait un
document par lequel les Européens disent
voilà quels sont les menaces qui pèsent
sur moi voilà quels sont les moyens que
je me donne pour y remédier et voilà mes
objectifs sur 30 ans c'est c'était
inconcevable le réseau français il y a
beaucoup contribué et pense que c'est
aussi un message d'espoir dans cet
univers très très désordonné très très
complexe très conflictuelle que nous
traversons et que nous sentons très bien
à propos de la crise de l'Ukraine voilà
merci
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour l'ensemble de ces
analyses nous avons un peu de temps pour
les questions parce que je pense qu'il y
en aura beaucoup alors on va lancer une
petite vidéo qui fait un rapide résumé
de des bilans de la présidente française
de l'Union européenne c'est Sylvain
vaserman qui l'a fait et puis je vais
commencer à prendre les premières
questions qui arrivent ici sur mon écran
donc c'est moi qui les poserai
tendance à dire que les moments
importants sont des moments historiques
pour la présidence française de l'Union
européenne ça a été plus que jamais le
cas d'abord bien sûr du fait des
circonstances avec la guerre en Ukraine
et l'incroyable mobilisation politique
de l'Europe des 27 aux côtés nos frères
ukrainien mais aussi dans des domaines
clés comme le réchauffement climatique
avec la décision des 27 de mettre en
place une taxe carbone aux frontières
c'était attendu depuis des décennies et
ça va enfin rééquilibrer les règles du
commerce international pour que chacun
contribue à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique deuxième
exemple l'avancée sociale en matière de
salaire minimum qui a été acté dans
chacun des pays européens
des avancées importantes aussi sur le
numérique pour dessiner le monde que
nous souhaitons et lutter contre
l'hégémonie des Gafa avec des directives
importantes qui ont abouti
sous-présidence française et puis je
conclurai avec un exemple qui est passé
un peu en dessous des radars médiatiques
le service civique européen sous
l'impulsion de la France qui est le pays
où le service civique qui est le plus
développé le président Macron a su
convaincre qu'il était important de même
que l'Europe a porté Erasmus de porter
des programmes de service civiques
européens c'est une façon de favoriser
développer l'engagement de la jeunesse
l'Europe en fait sous présidente
française c'est l'Europe telle que nous
la voulons une Europe audacieuse une
Europe politique forte une Europe
souveraine une Europe qui prend son
destin en main et c'est d'abord ça le
sens qu'il faut retenir de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne
alors les questions ont commencé à
arriver Oksana la première est pour vous
je la lis
comment voyez-vous l'évolution du
président zellenski entre le moment de
son élection et aujourd'hui comme chef
de guerre
parce que j'étais pas du tout partisan
de Linski
comme je suis plutôt dans les études
politiques et quand il y avait toute
cette cirque et le cinéma avec les
élections des hélinsky je me dis c'est
fini la politique je ferme l'ancien tank
je n'ai rien à analyser je n'ai rien à
faire c'est que de la politique c'est le
cinéma c'est le cirque il n'y a plus de
travail
et à vrai dire je critiqué au fur et à
mesure toutes les pas qu'il faisait et
tout bon j'étais vraiment dans
l'opposition bon je n'étais pas
partisans prochaine fois non plus bon je
suis difficile voilà mais
quand il a prononcé son discours à
Munich si vous souvenez le 18 février
c'est moi qui ai appelé parce que j'ai
plein copains comme c'est le monde du
cinéma on connaisse tous on est c'est
une petite bande maintenant qui
connaissent tous c'est une groupe d'amis
j'ai appelé un copain que je connaissais
les présidents et je disais écoutez je
pense qu'il a besoin de petites aide
dans la communication stratégique parce
que là il a prononcé le discours
politique dont il n'est pas conscient
il va avoir beaucoup de problèmes
maintenant il faut le soutenir et après
vous avez vous souvenez après les
rappelez-nous ce qu'il a dit dans ce
discours ah non mais il a animé les
choses il a comme il n'est pas du tout
dit diplômement admis le politique et la
cassette toutes les règles toutes les
femmes fortes il a commencé nommer les
choses comme ils sont il a commencé il a
dit que l'Europe est faible qu'il
n'arrive pas à défendre que ça fait 8
ans que l'ukrainement de la guerre à
l'est de l'Europe et on ne veut pas
reconnaître que c'est la guerre c'était
vraiment le discours de guerre et sa
santé guerre de toute façon il était en
courant que il y a les préparations bon
qui savait bien que ça va arriver du
jour au lendemain
et quand je commençais travailler avec
eux en communication
j'ai trouvé les questions tout de suite
pourquoi elle était élue parce que si il
était le politique classique
s'il était dans le cadre politique
diplomatique et tout
il pourrait jamais gagner
parce que ni lui ni l'entourage
classique ne pourrait pas supporter
cette première jour de la guerre c'est
seulement
les jeunes de génération de dos qui ont
maintenant entre 25 et 40 lui il a pris
ça combien de défis personnels en plus
il a joué un rôle du président déjà dans
le film
mais une défi qu'il a joué qui l'a vécu
dans ce film c'était quand il se
réveille le matin il n'y a personne tout
le monde était migré l'ukrain est vide
il est tout seul il y a juste une taper
le téléphonique dans son bureau du
président c'est un gamin qui dit
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous
c'était bon on a beaucoup rigolé à ce
sujet mais on pouvait jamais imaginer
qu'il y avait la guerre et pas les
migrations de tout le monde donc il a
quand même comme une comédien il a joué
plusieurs rôles y compris le rôle de
Léonid de trois Spartan sien et je pense
qu'il a pris ça comme une acteur prend
une rôle il faut jouer une rôle de
leader il faut dire qu'il a bien réussi
parce que tout le monde était conscient
que le comédien qui n'a pas de
compétences suffisant et tout le monde a
commencé à appeler les présidents son
Avignon à bangkovaya pour dire qu'est-ce
que nous pouvons faire il y avait toutes
les seigneurs de l'armée toutes les
seigneurs de la politique qui était
refusé par l'équipe des zlinski pour
travailler c'est eux qui gouvernaient
les premiers jours c'était toutes ces
vieux politiciens et surtout les gens de
l'armée qui savaient comment il faut
organiser la défense nationale et tout
et bien sûr
les peuple a été soulevé tout de suite
nos hommes ils nous ont dit
bon les femmes et les enfants vous
dégagez laissez nous faire notre travail
plus vite vous partez plus vite il n'y
avait aucune idée de partir moi aussi
moi non plus je voulais pas partir mais
nos hommes nous disent il faut partir ce
sera plus facile se battre comme ça tout
le monde était revenu autour de lui et
son évolué aussi d'une comédien vous
savez je pense que c'est peut-être
incarnation de l'idée de Chaplin quand
elle a parlé de dictateur
dans son imaginaire artistique et une
autre comédien au bout du monde des demi
siècles à réaliser ça c'est le comédien
une Chaplin devant le dictateur il gagne
vous imaginez l'état de Poutine je pense
qu'ici il va avoir la crise cardiaque
c'est parce qu'il perd devant une
comédien devant une clown
je crois une ski a vraiment illustré le
mot très profond d'Oscar Wilde la vie
imite l'art
c'est parfait
alors une question sur l'Italie et les
élections
de ce dimanche
Jean-Yves Le Drian je vais la lire
l'élection possible de Georgia Meloni en
Italie peut-elle changer modifier
sensiblement l'engagement de l'Europe
dans le conflit
ukrainien c'est difficile surtout en
public de faire un commentaire sur une
sur une évolution on veut pas faire lui
faire un commentaire sur une évolution
qu'on ne souhaite pas parce que parce
que l'élection pour nous je pense ici de
Georges ameloni n'est pas souhaitable et
que l'on peut peut-être regretter que
les conditions n'aient pas été réunies
pour que ailleurs tout un front
démocrate puisse se mettre en place de
manière significative parce que l'Italie
leur est mérité bon c'est un autre sujet
si d'aventure elle est élu je pense
qu'il y aura des divergences importantes
entre les équipes de Salvini de
Berlusconi et les siennes
peut-être que les déclarations de
Poutine il y a trois jours vont amener
des interrogations de lectorat
et peut-être que le résultat ne sera pas
celui que jusqu'à présent on imagine
mais si d'aventure c'était le cas les
prises de position de Madame mélonie sur
la question
ukrainienne sont très très fortes
et sont tout à fait en solidarité avec
les l'Alliance atlantique et avec les
Européens mais ce n'est pas le cas des
autres
Berlusconi c'est en illustré récemment
par des propos
très très complaisant les gares du
président Poutine donc il y aura des
difficultés sur la l'organisation
générale mais sur elle-même les propos
ont été très clairs et
l'affichage de la relation avec les
États-Unis de plus en plus affirmé
merci
prochaine question une question un peu
provoque pour Jean-Louis bourlange ne
pensez-vous pas que l'Alliance
atlantique a tué la défense européenne
tu disais c'est une question provoque ne
pensez-vous que l'Alliance atlantique
oui alors c'est ça c'est le si on résume
la si on formule cette façon stricte le
temps était en morse cérébrale le temps
est ressuscité et la défense européenne
est en mort cérébrale c'est c'est bon
alors écoutez on va essayer d'éviter ça
non c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire à la
fin de mon de mon propos c'est que c'est
évidemment extrêmement difficile quand
vous voyez
l'article 5 de l'OTAN et l'article 42 7
du traité de l'Union européenne c'est
exactement le même type de solidarité
mais
on peut pas exercer les deux solidarités
ensemble qu'est-ce qui se serait passé
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé si
Trump avait été aux affaires et s'il
avait dit on va lui c'est l'Ukraine etc
on s'en fiche les Européens et sans
doute fait de grandes démonstrations de
solidarité à l'égard des Ukrainiens
aurait accueilli les réfugiés aurait
offert son taxi le taxi dont il ne
voulait pas au président Zelinski et on
aurait beaucoup gesticulé mais on aurait
eu comment
on aurait eu beaucoup de mal maintenant
il s'agit effectivement de savoir c'est
ça le faux il y a une chose très
positive c'est la complémentarité des
actions la boussole stratégique
l'investissement technologique c'est ça
on peut faire beaucoup de choses dans le
dans le l'équipement dans la
modernisation de nos armées on peut
faire beaucoup de choses et on commence
à le faire on a créé la commission c'est
une mise pour la première fois depuis
des années dans dans ces responsabilités
militaires mais on atteint très vite
très vite la limite c'est à dire en cas
d'agression est-ce que nous sommes nous
Européens solidaires quand les
Américains sont là ça va si les
Américains disent bah non c'est une
affaire à vous etc est-ce que nous
serons solidaires car ça pose beaucoup
de problèmes ça pose d'abord un problème
politique est-ce que nous sommes
capables de faire l'effort
là je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
Jean-Yves Le Drian on a fait énormément
de progrès le ralliement du Danemark à
la politique extérieure sécurité commune
c'est un signe le ralliement de la
Finlande moi j'ai discuté avec le
président finlandais qui cette président
finlandais c'est des gens qui respectent
le Parlement il est venu à Paris il a
demandé à voir le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat et le président de la commission
de l'Assemblée nationale j'étais très
étonné il est venu dans mon bureau je
lui avais proposé d'aller à l'ambassade
en territoire est très content d'aller
au Parlement etc il est extraordinaire
le président finlandais et c'est l'homme
de c'est l'homme d'Europe qui connaît le
mieux Poutine il était avant qu'il entre
dans l'Union européenne mais il a il a
pris son temps il était un peu en
arrière de la main par rapport à sa
première ministre et il a il a fait le
choix très clairement et c'est un choix
qui est simultanément européen et
Atlantique le fait qu'il y ait
correspondance donc là je crois qu'on
peut pas considérer que le choix
européen que le choix finlandais ou le
choix suédois malgré les les évolutions
en Suède soit soit un choix de refus de
la défense de la défense européenne le
la variable essentielle c'est
l'Allemagne qu'est-ce que exactement
veut faire veulent faire les autorités
allemandes à mon avis ils ne sont pas du
tout au bout de leur évolution je crois
qu'ils ont fait trois prises de position
extrêmement importantes du chancelier
son discours tout à fait au lendemain de
l'invasion son discours
au bundeslag où il a vraiment montré que
il assumait la responsabilité d'une
confrontation avec la Russie son article
récemment où il a dit vraiment qu'il
voulait quelque chose européen son
discours de Prague mais le discours de
prime n'est pas fait pas une grande part
parce que moi qu'on puisse dire à
l'entente franco-allemande or en matière
de défense faut quand même dire on est
certainement beaucoup plus faible que
les Allemands sur le plan économique
mais en matière de défense on a force
nucléaire on est la première on est la
première puissance en capacité de
projection de l'Union européenne c'est
avec nous que ça se fera or pour
l'instant les Allemands n'ont pas
franchi n'ont pas franchi la barre de
quelque chose qui soit autonome alors là
on sort tout de suite à quelque chose
d'important est-ce qu'on fait ça dans le
temps ou en dehors de le temps c'est
comme la barbe non pas celle d'Edouard
Philippe la barbe du capitaine Haddock
est-ce qu'elle doit être au-dessus ou en
dessous de la de la du drap et là est-ce
qu'on pratique dans le temps où et là on
tourne autour de ça ça a des avancées
extrêmement difficiles de faire quelque
chose en dehors de le temps parce qu'on
ferait à ce moment-là une duplication de
la programmation et à l'intérieur de
latence c'est pas facile non plus parce
que les Américains sont partout donc là
on a des problèmes organisationnels des
problèmes de défi mais fondamentalement
la question vitale pour les européens
c'est est-ce que vous êtes capable
d'exposer votre vie votre votre
[Musique]
nation pour des raisons de solidarité
avec les ensembles avec les enfants
l'ensemble des Européens si les
Américains font des faux là on n'a pas
encore la réponse et je crois que c'est
ça la clé à l'avenir
je partage que peu de Mons qui vient de
dire Jean-Louis simplement la nouveauté
parmi les nouveautés il y a eu aussi
l'effort financier considérable que les
Européens ont décidé de faire pour leur
propre sécurité à commencer par les
Allemands qui étaient bien en retard
donc faut pas le regretter puisque on se
dote nous-mêmes de moyens
supplémentaires de capacité
supplémentaires la deuxième nouveauté
que qui nous avons évoqué l'un et
l'autre c'est le fait que les Européens
disent ensemble qu'il y a des intérêts
spécifiques européens qu'il faut prendre
en considération et qui peut y avoir des
menaces spécifiques au niveau des
Européens qui n'engageront pas les
États-Unis et qu'il faut être capable
auquel il faut être capable de riposter
ensemble
c'est ce qui s'est un peu passé au Sahel
même si l'opération malienne est
terminée il y avait 11 pays européens
qui étaient engagés aux côtés de la
France dans les opérations liées à la
sécurité au combat contre le djihadisme
au Sahel parce que les européens seront
des comptes que c'est leur propre
sécurité il y a un sujet sur lequel moi
j'ai des points d'interrogation
puisqu'on est face à des combats de
haute intensité
est-ce que pour rebondir ce que dit
Jean-Louis mais je pense qu'on pourra
pas y répondre aujourd'hui est-ce que
nous sommes en mesure serons-nous en
mesure un jour de riposter un combat de
haute intensité
vous vouliez compléter sur cette
opposition
Europe je voudrais vous proposer
regarder un peu autrement sur cette
question parce que quand même nous les
Ukrainiens ne considérons que la guerre
c'est la guerre en Europe pour l'Europe
et que maintenant vous avez devant vous
de naissance dont nouveau sujet
politique du géopolitique et c'est une
suggée c'est l'Ukraine et maintenant
c'est l'armée ukrainien qui tient les
routes c'est l'armée ukrainien qui
défend les valeurs européennes aux
frontières est de l'Europe donc je pense
que facteur de la présence de nouvelles
armées comme c'est l'armée ukrainien je
peux je peux vous jure que c'est une
armée la plus moderne maintenant la plus
performante
techniquement l'hermérus dépasse l'armée
ukrainien en 20 fois par quantité
d'armes quantité d'hommes quantité
toutes les effectifs qu'il y a derrière
dans le pays dans la Russie et on tient
la route ça veut dire que la stratégie
militaire maintenant
contemporain ça se développe chez nous
sur nos front en Ukraine donc je pense
que la question de la sécurité en Europe
et la défense en Europe ne peut plus se
jouer sans la présence ukrainien c'est
c'est pas parce que on veut s'imposer
mais parce que nous avons
malheureusement l'expérience que Dieu
merci personne d'autre parmi vous n'a
pas
et on voit bien qu'est-ce que c'est la
technologie de l'armée contemporaine et
la stratégie contemporaine parce que
j'ai
c'est pas peut-être quelque chose
nouveau pour vous mais je voudrais
répéter que aucun généraux qui est
maintenant à la guerre ne faisait partie
à l'armée soviétique c'est une nouvelle
génération des militaire c'est une jeune
génération des militaire ils ont tous
fait les stages et les études a droit à
droite non non pas en France beaucoup en
grand Bretagne notre chef de l'armée
messieurs zalujnie je l'aime beaucoup
c'est pour ça je parle beaucoup de lui
non et parce que c'est l'Hérault pour
toutes les Ukrainiens qu'on vous
imaginez c'est le numéro 2 après
zilinski lui il a une épée d'honneur qui
était lui offert par la reine et
Elisabeth doux quand elle a faisait son
stage à l'Académie royale en
Grande-Bretagne donc c'est vraiment vous
avez maintenant les officier très
performant l'armée qui est très motivée
qui a d'expérience
partout qui se battent pour avec les
drapeaux Ukrainiens quand même drapeau
européenne c'est très important donc je
vous invite de penser la sécurité
européenne avec le crème
c'est une perspective
dernière question dernière question va
se question
Marie-Pierre est peut-être une
conclusion de Jean-Yves Le Drian sur la
question de la Chine peut-elle être le
modérateur des États-Unis
tu as réussi la Russie oui pardon si
vis-à-vis on pourra après ouvrir cette
question pardon de la Russie sachant
qu'il y a déjà eu l'appel au cesser le
feu on pourrait poser dans d'autres cas
de cette question également
effectivement avec les outils mais en
fait je crois que de part de toutes les
interventions qui ont qui ont eu lieu on
a déjà répondu de fait en fait à cette
question le premier modérateur
c'est pas la Chine et quand Jean-Yves Le
Drian reprenait les 5 points justement
que Vladimir Poutine a sous-estimé en
fait on le voit bien l'ordre était pas
innocent dans la présentation des 5
points c'est pas le principal moteur
c'est un des éléments mais c'est c'est
d'abord et avant tout la réaction de
l'Ukraine et Jésus-Christ c'est ensuite
la réaction européenne la Chine arrive
après mais c'est vrai que et on en
discutait en apparentait avec Jean-Louis
bourge c'est vrai que la Chine elle
regarde éminemment ce qui se passe
éminemment l'unité de l'Union européenne
parce qu'on le sait bien que elle aussi
elle est focalisée sur Taïwan et ça fait
écho justement à
parce que disait Jean-Yves Le Drian dans
son dernier propos tout à l'heure c'est
les futurs autres menaces donc je pense
que le premier élément véritablement
c'est l'action de l'Ukraine et c'est le
soutien que l'Union européenne est
capable et doit continuer absolument
d'apporter à l'Ukraine et c'est ça qui
pourra faire évoluer la situation
réellement avant la Chine merci
Marie-Pierre
Jean-Yves Le Drian le mot de la fin nous
allons conclure cette table ronde
passionnante on pourrait
avoir plusieurs éditions on a encore
beaucoup de sujets qu'on a abordé pas
traité le risque que qui est devant nous
je rebondis sur la Chine et aussi en
partie sur le discours du président
Macron aux Nations Unies le risque est
devant nous c'est que la crise
ukrainienne
indirectement nous amène à une
confrontation de blocs qui suivrait la
conflictualité latente entre les
États-Unis et la Chine
il faut que nous évitions cette logique
là de la confrontation de deux
universalisme
parce que dans la stratégie chinoise il
y a aussi un universalisme qui se
traduit par les routes de la soie entre
autres mais au-delà aussi par un type de
modèle et de relations entre le centre
et la périphérie et donc
c'est une préoccupation que seuls les
européens peuvent développer et donc
s'il y a un message de la fin et qui
correspond d'ailleurs à aussi à
l'histoire du MoDem c'est le
l'engagement européen indispensable
unité européenne la vigilance c'est la
Suède qui va présider
l'Union européenne à partir de
l'épisode qui va suivre les épisodes
check et la Suède on voit ce que
aujourd'hui cette direction donc il
faudra être extrêmement vigilant au
cours de cette période qui précédera par
ailleurs les élections européennes mais
on est déjà là dans le débat à mon avis
qui va se produire au monde des
élections européennes qui sera
extrêmement intéressant aussi pour la
politique intérieure française parce que
ce clivage là il va être central et il
faudra
notamment là clairement affiché nos
postures nos propositions
merci merci infiniment à tous merci à
nos intervenants pour cette table ronde
passionnante on a tenu nos engagements
on rend l'antenne en temps et en heure
pour les prises de parole de Stéphane
séjourné Edouard Philippe